ma mère a fait trois choses pour moi une
venue puis elle m'a épargné la vie le jour
où je suis né je ne veux pas elle a
payé mon entretien à genoux et sur son
dos m'embrasse pourquoi en célébration de ma
méchanceté et trois elle m'a donné le
histoire je ne peux jamais dire s'il avait avec un
sacré que feriez-vous il y a un code
que nous survivons mon équipe c'est ellen est
écrit histoire dans son histoire elle dit
qu'elle vit avec des vampires
ma mère il y a du sang humain
fait depuis deux siècles
elle  est une aberration nous sommes des
femmes de la fraternité gharana au milieu d'une mer n'est-il pas
préférable de survivre
volons-nous du temps nous l'achetons
avec du sang nous sommes ici avant
petit ami
ceux qui sont prêts à mourir trouvent la vie éternelle